i don't care that they stole my idea
i care that they don't have any of their
own
of all things
i liked books best
the scientists of today think deeply
instead of clearly
one must be sane to think clearly
but one can think deeply
and be quite insane
if your hate could be turned into
electricity
it would light up the whole world
our virtues and our failings are
inseparable
like force and matter
when they separate
man is no more
life is
and will ever remain an equation
incapable of solution
but it contains certain known factors
we crave for new sensations but soon
become indifferent to them
the wonders of yesterday
are today common occurrences
what one man calls god
another calls the laws of physics
if you want to find the secrets of the
universe
think in terms of energy
frequency and vibration
the individual is ephemeral
races and nations come and pass away
but man remains
our brain has very sensitive nerve cells
which allow us to feel the truth
even when it is not yet available
time
will judge us
most persons are so absorbed in the
contemplation of the outside world
that they are wholly oblivious to what
is passing on within themselves
inventors don't have time for married
life
great moments are born great opportunity
the action of even the smallest creature
leads to changes in the entire universe
as i review the events of my past life i
realize how subtle are the influences
that shape our destinies
we are all one
only egos
beliefs and fears
separate us
when natural inclination develops into a
passionate desire
one advances towards his goal in seven
league boots
in continuous loneliness
the mind becomes sharper and sharper
ideas are born in the absence of
influence on the mind of external
efforts
a new idea must not be judged by its
immediate results
one salvation could only be brought
about through his own efforts
to know each other
we must reach beyond the sphere of our
sense perceptions
my belief is firm in the law of
compensation
the true rewards are ever in proportion
to the labor and sacrifices made
the hard work of the future
will be pushing buttons
intuition is something that is ahead of
accurate knowledge
there is nothing that could attract
human attention and deserve to be a
subject of study than nature
to understand a huge mechanism of nature
to discover its creative forces
and to understand its laws
this is the greatest goal of the human
mind
how many people called me a dreamer
our diluted myopic world scoffed at my
ideas
i guess i'll keep going
until i drop dead
the great mysteries of our existence
have yet to be solved
even death
may not be the end
a wise man should not marry
because no one can serve books and wife
alike
the secret to being creative alone
ideas are born in loneliness
avoid sex in old age
after it comes to kissing
and then talking
you